citizens of the reject Nation it is John
it is Tara Erickson back in the saddle
once again hi to check out a classic
Adam Sandler joint neither of us have
seen the water boy and that all changes
today Tara how you feeling hi
hi excellent me too listen up if you
want more of these reactions if you want
more Terra on the channel send the love
in the form of a like leave that on the
video helps out very much also subscribe
to the channel and when you do ring that
Bell
most certainly ring the bell for us ring
the bell for Tara Erickson's Channel as
well as La eats and drinks which is her
online food Excursion oh yeah baby I'll
take you around Los Angeles Eaton and
drinking La eats and drinks with me go
on the journey absolute vodka and hey
before we hop into this one last thing
why don't you join us over at the
patreon if you want to get the full
experience of the water boy see
everything that doesn't make these
reaction highlights it is a blast sync
up with your own copy patreon.com the
real rejects we've got tons of fun stuff
over there so without further Ado let's
watch this
[Music]
thank you so much Sean something like
that cut you out just pretend like I did
it agua hombre
[Music]
Bayou Blues I have never been to a swamp
oh you should go seeing a lot of swamps
in movies never been to one a lot of
great swamps across the country comment
below with your favorite tell me the
favorite swamps I'll go
oh whoa damn that is a an aggressive
title smash from the outside it looked
like it was run down
that's how I like to wake up every
morning
I'm gonna get a few good hits in before
we start reacting for the day sure sure
he does you've got a good looking
football team maybe good enough to add
another national championship trophy to
the old case the only thing better than
a crawfish dinner is five crawfish
okay
I'm gonna try and do the rest of the
reactions in the coral fish it's a gold
accent
nah he's gonna be a hero just you watch
look at this contraption a plus it's
clean it's cold and that's what I call
high quality
all right the highest quality H2O what
is it [__] doing here he does a great
job disrupting my football team you
idiot 18 years of this is enough
18 years yes 50 calls for you you're far
oh pretty sure he has tenure by now yeah
Cajun County I love me a Cajun sauce oh
yeah oh my God Kathy Bates is in this
all right let's do this got character
actors Galore I bet oh my God that's
where I want to go can you guys please
tag where that building is that's where
I want to go now you'll be able to spend
your days at home where you belong
I could try to to get another water
board job for a different team don't you
raise your voice to me Bobby Boucher
I don't like confrontations I'm a Virgo
who told you you was a Virgo that that
that girl who told you Virgo's avoid
confrontations
[Music]
I went down to Georgia
Louisiana you seem to be sweating quite
profusely
perhaps you might need this services and
experienced water board yes put yourself
out there how old are you kid 11 12. I
I'm 31 years old
I bet that was a trailer moment oh God
what is that guy's name he's huge so
this is where they strip the ball from
us whoops he has time to pick it up and
dust it off and running for a touchdown
before our guys even know what's going
on David Spade's voice
oh no this is Henry Winkler I am
inquiring as to whether you have the
need for an experienced Waterboy on your
upcoming season nice suit
there's a flanker lined up to the left
once the quarterback has the ball he
fakes to the left
no fakes to the right
he doesn't think
he pretends to fake
huh
I don't know where I am
the same hang on here hey come on
Prime Time honor boy
delicious water
it's good this is much better than what
I serve
oh thank you I will do it for free just
promise me that you will never
distribute the content of that drug to
any human poison puts hair on your chest
oh hey oh nice oh God they have to swap
it that's good oh wow hey you know save
some plastic yeah okay
uh just have the defense run sprints
I'm trying to decide oh man now we're
with that kind of [__] where are we
going this way
I'm determined to be able to decipher
what he is saying I feel like okay it's
no way
what is better cold that the H2O is
purified it's good to use the heating
Source story no my mama always has
better safety than sorry my mama says
that too I don't know Mama's the same
uh-huh cooperation I need it now used to
be an assistant coach at some big
football school but he had a mental
breakdown or something seems like he
might still be having it
it's a really prolonged breakdown
[Music]
all of that precious water you're only
hurting yourselves yeah Jagged is out
oh my God you're gonna have to drink out
of that dummy check this out
yes he happens to be a finely tuned
athletic machine and I ain't gonna have
him hitting the head by some idiot water
ball do you understand me oh
core memory you gotta defend yourself
here Bobby they didn't find it yeah tune
the athletic machine I'm not telling you
to go on a shooting rampage whoa
thank goodness stinky
they're all going to laugh at you
oh yes oh yeah
I would be honored if you if you play
football for this team my mama won't let
me play no football you and I want to
talk to Mama mama said my Mama said Mama
said Mama Mama say Mama
say Mama
[Music]
I just love the Devil Went Down To
Jordan as like their establishing music
for home yeah
let's talk about Bobby playing football
you see my boys too delicate to be
playing foosball and whatever you call
it with them Gargantuans
Gargantuans my husband Robert he decides
he's gonna go and join the Peace Corps
if he got lost in the middle of the
Sahara Desert he died at the dehydration
oh you know when I was your age my
mother told me not to get a tattoo of
Roy Orbison
or is it like on his butt I thought he
was gonna show us but mama don't know
won't hurt her
yeah I knew it oh my God I knew it
you're a comedy genius
I completely forgot that would be part
of the conceit of this like a few
minutes ago I was like how are they
gonna make a whole movie
we're getting a little old you can share
mine you try it on man see if it fits
all right okay friend oh a dick
don't listen to him no former Water Boy
Bobby Boucher is going to play some
linebacker for us now I want to work
with the offense I want to work with the
defense special teams go with former
Fran do some laps
I want that to be my internal monologue
just on a daily basis
I want you to tackle Casey like you did
Gee yesterday right now right now go
does he know about this does it matter
come on Warrior boy
like a like an awkward nice hug you know
a physical sport boxing hockey who's
your favorite wrestler insane
I'm gonna have to take Captain insane I
want you to do to Casey what Captain
insano does to the bad guy this captain
and say no A Healer face though
come on buddy
[Music]
I want you to think about all those mean
people they're going to be your tackling
fuel we're going to use them to play
football tackling fuel
I want you to visualize and then attack
not to add
you having a much better day today coach
Mr coach I feel like you could just yell
at him
welcome around
stupid to do what your coach tells you
no no what
all right there we go all right all
right can you do this for me every
single game can you do this oh not only
will I do it for you I
at
yes yes I'll do it for you
[Laughter]
that was that was very funny now is
there anyone here tell me why most
alligators are abnormally aggressive I
know the answer to this question raise
your hand anybody
oh
mama says that alligators are ornery
because they got all them teeth but no
toothbrush
oh wow
alligators are
an enlarge medulla oblongata that is
correct noted
you can tell me where happiness comes
from
happiness is from Magic rays of sunshine
I come down when you're feeling blue
that's sweet Mama's wrong again Mama's
an idiot
Mama's right something wrong with his
medulla oblongata
[Music]
last demonstration
his glasses flew off his head kick off
another year of Mud Dog football with
the weight of a 40-game losing streak on
their back
40. wow see what's great about going to
a school with no football team is you're
never defeated
I feel bad about lying to my mama I
wonder what she doing right now
[Music]
I'll bet you 50 bucks throws touchdown
pass on the first play Clint Howard
[Applause]
ah clean interceptions
you owe me 50 bucks you said it was
going to be a touchdown pass you crazy
[__] I love that they have the one
guy in fake teeth and I think those are
just Clint Howard's actual teams yeah
yes watch where you're going needle
hmm do you want to win like that guy has
a huge medulla oblongata but a not so
huge
um
[Applause]
nice sacking them
there we go baby
[Applause]
first time they've scored in six years
dude like guys uh be nice to him I mean
he's making you win games no one's that
mean that long we're tied at seven with
30 seconds to go in the fourth quarter
on an upcoming play I'll be playing with
your mama tonight 62.
like a screen pass
hey
thank you what the oh so that he could
tackle him was that his thought are you
gonna catch up buddy
that's some martial arts right there
nice job [__] you just lost us the
game would you please still be my fan no
get away from me okay
okay buddy
nice blues music
down the mood
oh Fairuza bulk just got out of jail I
heard you were playing football yes well
I I we live up by another day we live up
by on our day
if we go and get something to eat and
catch up on things Mama's not a a big
fan of restaurants or uh of of me going
to one
if you'd like on a Sunday afternoon
there's a a a grill with a charcoal
biscuit you want me to come to a
barbecue yes that's it mm-hmm
a grill with a charcoal biscuit I hope
you like what I did to y'all lawnmower
she's awesome hell's yeah you need to
come do that to my lawnmower
oh my god oh no
I don't believe in that sort of thing
personally astronomy is one of the many
tools of the devil yes correct yes thank
you for saying that
is in the star
foosball
oh Bobby yeah Roy Orbison can't
they have a catch that gorilla would
escape from the zoo and punched you in
the eye
what
oh my goodness cover best cover what do
you think if Bobby did play football
Mitsubishi I don't think much of you and
all your snotty questions I'm quite
Disturbed to see that you're so
interested in my boy I'm very very
interested in your boy oh okay did he
tell you about a little bedtime problem
Mama I'm begging you don't that's a
sheep back there
oh excuse me ladies I'm gonna go hang
myself oh no buddy no that that woman is
a devil and I want you to stay away from
me you hear me now you come on inside
for that little witch Castle spell on us
oh but she fixed his lawnmower I'm sorry
Mickey Mouse such a cool name gonna fix
his heart by the end and it is
no bones no bones in that little
alligator the amazing 31 year old
freshman set a new NCAA record by
sacking the quarterback 16 times Bobby
Boucher is also the team's Waterboy what
exactly are they putting in the water
down at Jackson's Bayou Louisiana
oh yeah I bet you feel real dumb right
now look at you switch that burger out
for a big old plate of crow cut to him
crying in the corner mean old man first
string quarterback Tommy Gardner does
not have a broken name
excellent that's great to hear her I
forbid you to talk to that enchantress
she's the devil uh oh she's the most
beautiful woman in the world
she was the devil the most beautiful
woman in the world oh please don't hurt
me
scramble on this quarterback
though
I love you so much Mom I love you oh I
love you too yes finally a nice football
player it's gonna be a big party tonight
baby let's go here we go
this is that must have been a popping
soundtrack back in 90 whatever feel
looser the pressure is off and that will
lead to a lot more victories yeah that
in a Waterboy getting 20 sacks a game
that too that water Diamond does look
good yeah we still haven't had test on
amphibians and reptiles next Friday
yes sir oh my best regards to your Dear
Mama oh I see at this party yeah what
are you doing there buddy and you are so
cute is there a girl you're seeing I I
see a lot of girls I see a lot of guys
too I think that's sexy yeah there we go
it's terrible John
the gorilla they gotta catch that damn
gorilla
not bad what molecule is that
I suppose I had to be moving on if I get
you into trouble tell Mama Mr coach
client said that what mama don't know
won't hurt it
maybe we could ride home together in
that Porsche
[Music]
feels like one of those quintessential
like 90s yeah like her look yeah yes and
just I don't know that like energy it's
a Vibe yeah the 90s vibe that you're
like I want to hang out with her yeah
she's got like you know obviously you
got like the craft like she can be the
the bad girl or you know like a
formidable character but you also can
just fall in love She's sweet too yeah
because you're interested in astrology
and mystical stuff like that you might
appreciate this
water from a glacier in Alaska wow
blessed by a an Eskimo medicine man
it's cold
yes it's always cold that that's why
it's so special wow that's cool
okay
becoming a man today it would do I never
did that before that was your first kiss
and I bet it's the first time you've
seen a pair of these oh my oh my
goodness that is another voice for me
and I I appreciate what what you show me
right now
the devil devil
[Laughter]
I mean sometimes I just don't know why
I'm bother with you you ain't even a man
ah Bobby Boucher is doing great on the
field not great in the bedroom
it's okay by the end water sucks
[Applause]
now you've done it uh oh he's mad now
better not see one cup of Gatorade
Gatorade is the devil tastes better too
idiot you're you're drinking the wrong
water Gatorade
H2O
it really really sucks
[Music]
dude
there we go you're learning boy yes he
saw boobs and now he's a winner there is
a direct correlation between the two
absolutely it reminds me just about how
special this season really was
you
[Applause]
you we've got
a young man who has been so vital to our
success and a wonderful friend oh Bobby
Boucher hey all right he gets a little
party was this the first Rob Schneider
you can do it
thank you so much
for being my friends
oh I
just want a button that plays that you
fixing to tackle all of us
can't get water love and ask Greg I
asked you a question dumbass
whoa whoa I saw your head off you can do
it God just head off
yes we don't want this to get physical
right client this is not how ambassadors
for the University of Louisiana's
supposed to die so now you just get back
on the bus
oh
he damaged the coach too assault with a
deadly weapon get her a little country
ass out of here oh dang he's ready
Mickey's the best this is
a transcript South Lafayette High School
and Cherokee Place Louisiana it ain't no
South Lafayette High School in Cherokee
Plains Louisiana this is a fake
oh my this is from the NCAA they don't
think you ought to play football no more
damn it if you didn't go to high school
Bobby I was homeschooled I didn't know I
needed for as a fake transcript
if the water boy's a cheetah don't
change the fact that the real mud dogs
are gonna kick some cougar ass my dog my
dog my dogs my dogs my dogs okay
[Applause]
let's go let's go team
I also like that the coach smelt off to
Waterboy dressed like a Dixie cup
oh he just has to stand there and watch
yeah sad the NCAA is going to allow you
to play in The Bourbon Bowl yes you just
have to pass the high school equivalency
test everybody
hates me
that's not true
oh no
that hurt somebody made me look like a
cheater I did it I did it I did it I did
it I did it what he forged it why
because it was the only way to get you
in I came into my office I went under my
desk I cried oh
oh
boy
he's not gonna be cooking chicken
anytime soon 20 years ago we were
assistants to coach Kavanaugh boy was I
good
I would write these foolproof plays in
my little green notebook that I had
[Music]
him look at him go coach Kavanaugh was
going to retire me and red we just knew
that one of us was going to be a
successful splash of color Schindler's
Waterboy
that was his green book
[Music]
filthy Rock stealer are we in all that
green notebook you use right on him
football plays man well I need to show
Kavanaugh that I can come up with some
good play ideas
through my place
I need them
[Music]
[Laughter]
don't forget to hit that notification
Bell friends
next day fired me once he had my
notebook he didn't need me anymore and
that's breakdown happened I can't
believe it myself I'm so oh oh god oh I
just hate him I hate him I hate him
a little uh Norman batesy over here okay
well you're gonna show him yeah you're a
man on Saturday and I'm gonna show
everybody that I'm not a dummy you got
this you both got this come on now what
you reading for because
sitting there all grouchy mama I gotta
read this book and six other books
tonight or else I can't play foot
up toe
you planned a foosball behind my back so
I can go to school school you going to
school
ugh you gonna lose all your Fenty
foosball games and you're gonna fail
your big exam because school is the
devil oh
well I like school and I like football
and I'm gonna keep doing a boat because
they make me feel good there you go and
by the way Mama alligators are ornery
because
[Laughter]
see you learned something and I like
Vicky and she likes me back
and she showed me her boobies and I like
them too
much but it's good it's all on the table
it's just a 300 multiple choice
questions
you have three hours
good luck to you sir
I remember scansron's boy
there's a small town
[Laughter]
that's what the meme is from
seeing that as a gift with no context a
thousand times Vicky is the best
dude she's got she's got a memes under
her belt too yeah
[Music]
come on Bobby
oh what your mama got sick this morning
oh she's in the hospital
what have I done
slowed down version
[Music]
she got broken heart because of me
everybody else in this town trying to
meet at the job of a hat mama is the
only one who really cares if I live or
die oh she's a faker what hospital
allowed this
oh my goodness that's a great cut too
you got the house to yourself no you
made the hospital look like home
[Laughter]
too because he's like made it look like
yeah insane
[Music]
oh
assemble the Avengers yeah get them
together
wow wow
yes all right best lives over here
getting it
[Applause]
wish we had little candles in plastic
cups however they're actually just
shoved through plastic cups all these
folks are here tonight to tell you that
they're sorry and one of them wants to
say something come on
oh
okay you're an inspiration to all of us
who who weren't born handsome and
Charming
it's okay you're doing great
[Music]
and how much you're playing football
means to this town but she can't hear
you cause she's unconscious
oh
go to the window mama
do the right thing
mama I was so bad mama you were right
about everything I've been a real
knucklehead baby you should have seen
this a long time ago daddy is that my
daddy no no this guy I dated before I
met your father oh you get on a shirt on
his stomach
Daddy
so handsome
who's Helen that's my first name Bobby
oh
my goodness I'm sure I had no problem
finding work so you can expect my next
letter to contain lots of money oh but
sorry no money yet Nolan's is an
expensive city
to whom it may concern oh geez we have
Grown Apart over these last six weeks
two loves in my life
big city living and a voodoo woman named
Phyllis oh ciao Roberto ciao I was so
scared you'd abandoned me too
I've made you abandon all those people
who depend on you but I can't hug you to
myself no more because everyone's seen
how wonderful you are
you're not the devil after all
you go play foosball with your friends
yes yeah Red's got a couple of solid
early rounders out there hey
[Music]
I know their names they're just not
right now
I Sports sometimes
Madden no that was not John man at least
I would at least a name better than me
kickoff is a beauty
[Music]
oh you're gonna run it okay nine yards
deep come on
[Applause]
damn they're showing no respect for this
team whoa oh boy oh boy okay
touchdown cougars they strike first all
right damn it off to a great start
yes
wow that's awesome
yeah where can I go on one of those
Remember the Time Bobby tackled the
referee by mistake about the time we
tackle the guy from Louisville and threw
him into the stance
is he supposed to be like a sling blade
parody I don't know
harder
showed up at halftime minute my dog's
won the bourbon ball you yeah
in a dramatic turn of events Bobby
Boucher just arrived at halftime and on
a fan boat Brett his mother drove right
into the stadium
that's great right to the stadium
if only we could have seen that water
boy water or boy Rudy Rudy
Sports chant
it's a reverse
nice yeah there we go fumble recovered
that's what I like to see
knocked the Boop out of him
poop
[Music]
oh he's gonna do some play from the
green book and maybe the Henry Winkler
will see it and it will bring him back
to life it'll like awaken he'll be like
that's my old play from
1972.
[Music]
what is red bow you doing refusing to
play offensive yeah this is bizarre oh
red is taking the water boy out of the
game by kneeling down three times in
punting he's going to make the mud
offense try to beat him the way they're
playing today that's impossible ugh that
means coach Klein will have to find
another way to out Fox red please come
on think of that green book are you
afraid of Red Bull you
[Applause]
damn book
yeah somebody not a fatal and then
attack that you told me
come on get your fawns on
that's terrifying oh
now this is what we're gonna do he's
gonna come here yes all right we've
unlocked it let's go
do this
[Music]
trick plays going let's get them shovel
passes
[Applause]
[Music]
that's what I like to see
red is sending his best defender in as a
running back okay
no no sir I'm gonna take matters into my
own hands you'll see bring it to the
hole
meanie with an ey oh boy sound like a
big choo-choo train
he does kind of sound like a train
[Applause]
compliment of Captain insano yes yeah
wrestling nice call back wrestling saves
lives visualize
the ball kick it
[Music]
oh yes yes oh my goodness clear out of
the stadium
foreign
[Applause]
yeah live your best life
Oh weird play
what are they doing
love it dang
switching it up
[Music]
yeah
there we go
battering around that was awesome
[Music]
Red Bull you is steaming there Brad he
sees his perfect season slipping away
[Music]
it's called karma Bobby Boucher is now
on the kickoff team last game of the
year Brent can't hold anything back now
I know
[Laughter]
[Music]
that was a cheap shot flag I'm not sure
the Boucher is able to get back up
no Bobby
he just needs some water oh yes the
Glacier Glacier Water
that's gonna save him
[Music]
that's high quality H2O
has a whole ass Kip up it's gonna be
hard to do in football gear oh boy just
need just needed some water
[Applause]
you think that up all by yourself
oh man oh man back and forth I have an
idea for the last play the offense is
going to line up like this yeah you're
gonna be right here there'll be no tie
here today coach Klein is sending his
offense back he's got a new green book
now buddy yours is outdated Bobby
Boucher is back on the field he is now
playing offense we know it's the last
game of the season okay
do not bet him get away do you
understand me do you understand me get
in there I'm ready friend let's do it
Bobby
all right
[Music]
cool not Vangelis but but same Vibe yeah
Vangelis circus Sports Center
[Music]
love it love it is he gonna make it easy
gonna make it
it's a cool shot come out
[Music]
get them Sticky Fingers
well done
I do love the commentary there's so much
commentary on Sports is like pretty
obvious
Professor colonel
iest
[Applause]
he loves his mama
[Music]
oh all right
well deserved
you're gonna become a man good night
this is the best day of my life
what was gonna happen tonight you'll see
you can do it you can do it all night
long
I'm sorry you can
Daddy
oh he was talking about you being
drafted by the NFL not going to the NFL
I'm going to stay in school and graduate
the hell with school don't be take the
money you and me could be oh she's gonna
tackle him that's great
[Music]
I hope he gets it from his mama
love it
get him and you go on have some fun
becoming a man
oh that's sweet crazy belly they got on
his daddy there all right
come on you got all the extra horsepower
floor of that thing yeah come on now
ah that was cute that was cute that was
that was fun
also what happened to
uh
the guy in the beginning who was the
first guy on the team to befriend him
and be nice to him he we heard like two
things from him in the beginning he was
like here you can share my helmet and
then like he wasn't he didn't say
anything at all like I thought I thought
it's going to be yeah but like why did
it later why were they like friends I
mean like he's not like a huge character
but he's there throughout being like
yeah you were still like friends but I
was like Oh I thought that he would have
a conversation with him that he would
like he would go hey man like listen
like it's gonna be fine like do this I
got you yeah yeah you know I think he
will be like his his prominent male
buddy male buddy that we kind of didn't
see except I guess it was the coach like
he serves he does yeah I guess I just
wanted to see that a little bit you were
in the relationship yeah I just really
liked how it was in the beginning how
nice he was he was like the only one
that was like it's fine man we can share
my helmet like I thought that was so
sweet and I wanted them I wanted to see
more of their friendship yeah yeah no I
would agree with that for sure I mean I
I appreciated the the various
relationships but like yeah yeah there
was a lot I know I don't know
yeah Vicki and the coach and everything
so yeah I think like a different version
of the script or blah blah blah whatever
but I would have enjoyed that too so
right because I like that guy like and I
I know I've seen him before and I
thought he you know had a lovely
presence yeah and he had one gold tooth
which I have always wanted in my life
why don't you get a little tooth I I
haven't I don't feel like I've earned it
yet yeah I feel like I have to reach a
point where I'm like you know like
killing the game and I got like
independent wealth to the point where
making a choice like that it doesn't
really matter to the bottom line right
you know so right give it give it five
ten years okay and then I'll go gold
I'll give it 20. thank you yeah for
handicapping me yeah yeah but yeah this
was a delight like I I you know like
we've said you know what I realized we
made it through this whole reaction with
Mary a a drink of water I feel like we
we failed we should have happened here
the whole time I have my water in my
shoe and I didn't drink and there you go
you go you got to make up for the both
of us now but like I missed a good
amount of like the Adam Sandler Classics
growing up we just weren't like a
Sandler house and there's always that
debate going back for these movies of
what did you have to be there for at the
time and what just holds up anyway and I
feel like there are two lanes like
sometimes they're Adam Sandler things
where I see him and I'm like I feel like
I'm just aware that it's you and it's
and then it's you doing your kind of
stick or whatever whereas I like a movie
like this where he is committed to a
character and just you know sort of
earnestly playing the character yeah and
uh and so yeah I appreciate just the
kind of yeah just earnestness he he
brings to something like this anyway
yeah I liked also the casting of Vicky I
forget our name but I really like her
yeah she's great like what happened to
her where is she yeah I feel like she
still pops up and stuff but there was
that period of time where she was huge
right yeah she was like one of those
like it girl like so in so many things
and two with that like edgy Vibe and
everything and I feel like Kathy excuse
him off I didn't get enough sleep dude
and I feel like Kathy Bates was also
brainwaters
we're dehydrated we're dehydrated that's
yes dehydrated reaction and Kathy Bates
was like also huge at this during this
time oh yeah I feel like my bra was
showing the entire reaction not like a
lot but a little so you know if you saw
a bra it's just I didn't know it was out
yeah
I didn't know
um it's okay
yeah be a very innocent uh viewers here
oh really yes huh they don't even know
what a bra is I feel like they're gonna
get mad at you for calling them innocent
uh you know they can come at me in the
comments we're making it what are the
Innocents gonna do apologize
run rings around you logically oh yeah
yeah it's one of those movies that kind
of lived up to about you know the
expectation I would have had but uh it
achieved its goal it's fun it was
delightful it's got its raunchy elements
and sometimes that's not my favorite
kind of Comedy it never really bothered
me here though like you know there there
are moments like oh you got the donkey
drinking out of the toilet that are like
a little bit obvious a little bit like
you know haha you know vague poop joke
or whatever but for the most part like I
appreciated the earnestness yeah that's
kind of the word I come back to do you
have all these absurdly mean characters
around him and just like the sweetest
ever guy in Bobby and and I mean part of
me got curious cause I'm like you know
they do address at least with him like
you don't have all like the you don't
know social cues very well and things
like that and he's got the stutter and
he's got you know his specific demeanor
and at the time I'm like you know I'm
sure this is just like a character that
he cooked up but two like now that we're
more aware of psychology I'm just like
curious as to like what people's
thoughts are you know on just the Aging
of this character because again it is
played so earnestly and he is so
committed to it right doesn't seem like
it's some kind of flippant like I'm
gonna create this caricature even though
there is certainly height to it yes um
so yeah it's like you know I feel like
this a movie like this can exist on a
slippery slope but it didn't feel too
tasteless in being that right like I
mean today he wouldn't be able to make
it but like looking at it now it's I
agree with the earnestness yeah right
yeah and like it's there's so many
characters laughing at him but I feel
like the movie itself isn't and I think
that's kind of the key like I feel like
you you might be able to but I feel like
if you did try to make this now there
would be sort of a different
feeling or a different conversation to
have before
clearing this to be what it is you know
yeah yeah a much bigger conversation
versus I think back in the the 90s was
this made yeah right really yeah it's
got to be yeah I mean I don't what is it
is this 1998 that's all
it's been a lot of time in 1998 ladies
yeah dang yeah okay and I'm looking here
and it says Bobby Boucher is a socially
inept stuttering and somewhat mentally
challenged 31 year old man and it's like
I am fascinated to on just to hear how
people think this has aged certainly
given just again yeah the way the
conversation shifts I and I do think
that it avoids being tasteless because
the core of the movie seems like it's
trying to be compassionate towards Bobby
and to lift him up so you know and
clearly he's capable and can learn but
also yeah it's one of those things that
makes me curious yeah and two like I'm
thinking back because a lot of these I
feel like I I wish I had my sports brain
on better because like Lynn Swann was in
here and uh a number of other like
famous commentators and stuff like that
many of whom are still you know active
and and commentating and whatever today
who you know when I do catch football uh
you know sort of passing through rooms
during the season you know I will see
those faces still and hear those voices
so I feel bad if I didn't catch you know
this is one of those movies where I
think yeah even partly through the
reaction I was like I bet there are a
lot of like random Sports cameos in here
because obviously there should there
must be oh yeah yeah Adam Sandler had
could get whoever he wanted in the 90s
early 2000s to be in whatever movie he
made through that I mean he got Jennifer
Aniston when she was on friends she did
not need to be in any movies oh dang
right I mean she didn't I mean Adam
Sandler's great but I'm saying whoever
he wanted to choose from he could get
yeah
like they dated heck yeah well
she was she was in that the movie and
like the uh early 2000s with him and
recently last year she was in another
one for him there they've definitely
been friends since yeah but she's been
in a lot of projects with Adam Sandler
he knows how to get the cool peeps
that's right you know people must like
working with the Sandman yeah and I mean
too you got I really enjoyed Henry
Winkler in this I thought he did a nice
job straddling the line again between
earnestness and silliness giving this
guy such like a a Sad Sack genuine
quality to so many of the like goofy
things they have him do but also enough
that you buy it when he's like you know
kind of getting over this hump with the
other coach that Kathy Bates did a
really nice job and and two like holding
down that accent and and making this
character that's like an antagonist but
that you don't fully hate and yeah the
way she comes around like you know
there's a lot of stuff that you could
yeah you can predict about how the movie
is going to go it's it's classic in a
lot of ways just the various sort of
random recurring characters Clint Howard
uh you got your Rob Schneider you can do
it which uh which this has to be one of
the early instances of that of them
trading that Cameo back and forth I
don't know if it's the first one but but
yeah this is it's a fun time capsule
because I remember people when this came
out being just so much about it and kids
quoting it and doing the Bobby Boucher
voice and stuff like that it's filling
in this this part of my my you know
memory that's been echoing for so long
you know
yeah I feel like the only character that
wasn't as so corny and classic that you
could see it coming was Vicki's
character because she could have easily
been a blonde hot girl that have been
that in my brain I'm I don't know what
movie I'm thinking but just like blonde
hot fit girl in any Adam Sandler movie
that's like yay and she's just like
really cute and dumb uh except Vicky had
some like she's like I fixed your
lawnmower to have a V12 engine in it and
also I'll kill these people for you
because I just got out of jail which I
adore like I love her character when we
look at it because it could very have
easily gone the other way and not have
had as much of an impact in the
storyline like you could have easily
just gone I don't want her to be a cool
badass girl with like dark hair and just
out of jail they could go great we'll
just supplement her with like a blonde
girl who's nice and sweet and it's not
gonna change the storyline as much right
yeah um so I like what they gave to
Vicky like she whips out a knife and is
about to kill the coach I just I love
that all of those those parts with her
unpredictable for me I did not see those
coming the rest of it was like oh all
right once I realized I can't be playing
this like they're mean to him as a water
boy for an hour and a half right then I
was like oh he's gonna play football
yeah after that you're like okay I get I
get what this is gonna be with him and
Mom and stuff like that but Vicky was
the one that I was like oh the stuff
that's coming up for her character I did
not predict and I very much enjoyed it
yeah they make you like her and she is
distinct from so many of this so much of
the status quo around him and it has a
very different attitude from all the
people around him so yeah it's like even
though she is edgy they do kind of make
like an actual character out of her yeah
somebody that you do want to see open up
his world a little bit you do want yeah
it's like you know that could easily
just be requisite and like you only care
so much as like the the immediate moment
of the movie requires hopefully and
achieves it was one of those elements
that had a little more flavor and
personality than I was maybe expecting
it's like they're both oddballs but in a
in a Charming way yeah he's so innocent
he's so sweet and naive and and you know
he doesn't he's you know clearly
acquiring knowledge and I like that too
it's like clearly he's capable you know
clearly he's intelligent he just needs
to be given the opportunity to learn and
uh and so yeah you have his innate
sweetness and then her innate edginess
but still that good nature between them
and like that was yeah that was like a
character thing that was interesting as
well as amusing yeah it's very much like
elf except elf I think was executed uh I
lost you know I get where you're coming
and elf was like executed in a totally
different way
um but it's very much like you know it's
the same character thing of like he
needed some guidance he wasn't all there
right he's like elf and I live in with
Santa and then he meets uh Zoe does
Chanel who's a little harsher and then
brings him to the light and they get
married and live a great life it's like
it's a lot like elf which I and I love
Elf so much that's one of my favorite
movies
it is terrific it is it's probably the
most recent sidebar of all the crew
I can think of maybe one other but like
you know how like in the Canon of
holiday songs it's like you know after a
certain point in time there aren't
really that many Classics yeah it's like
with Christmas with holiday movies there
aren't really a lot of like no this is
one for the all-time Hall of Famers you
know like the Pilates here and Elvis elf
is one of them one and elf is maybe not
the most recent one I could think of but
it's damn near close it's stinking it's
close and even the other ones I'm
thinking of I'm like I don't know if
everyone would agree with me where I
feel like most people would be like yeah
elf is a holiday classic elf Jim carries
the Grinch and
um oh what's my other one oh then The
Nightmare Before Christmas is pretty
cool yes yeah that was a sidebar but we
went there it's okay I'm resisting
Christmas in July but it's June it's
fine we're like 20 days early John it's
okay it'll be Chris we can do a whole
Christmas reaction can we do it in July
sure sure definitely maybe that'll work
better than when we did
and I'm like I hope this picks up around
Christmas you know or maybe we can
promote it again in July oh my gosh but
yeah Christmas is July you should wait
till the holidays John I just couldn't
wait I just I just could not wait that's
a great movie yeah yeah that's a super
fun movie David Harbor Santa all day
every day
um but yeah I want to look out I want to
get a list of of all the the like famous
uh players yeah the Cameo appearances
Lynn Swann Lawrence Taylor Jimmy Johnson
Bill coward coward coward Dan Fouts
Brent Musburger Chris Fowler Lee Corso
Dan Patrick Lawrence Taylor Paul that
was the Big Show too was insano I knew I
recognized him and I've seen him since
then couldn't draw it to name but yeah I
appreciated that the film was extremely
profitable I mean it seemed like I mean
Adam Sandler at the time certainly
seemed like yeah wow one of the key you
know certainly it was like his own
cottage industry him and Jim Carrey I
guess maybe like a Martin Lawrence or
something like that like you know guys
who were like always coming out with
these big old comedies and everybody
around me three times a year right like
crazy yeah and everybody all the kids
around we're all seeing them you know
it's like it's weird I have the
association just because everyone I know
was watching these movies when I wasn't
so I I had to be part of many
conversations of people talking about
the movies and not really participating
because I was just like I can't I don't
know what you're talking about I have
not seen such a thing
you know what's funny is that I was in
this movie in 2012 it's a feature film
called waking except Adam Sandler wanted
to buy waking he liked the script a lot
and he was like but I can't go like it's
gonna have to be me and whoever I cast
right and uh luckily my my friend who
wrote it and then produced it Skyler
Caleb
um was like nope sorry and so it's it's
me and and Skyler and magsione and a
bunch of other people Tim Daley's in it
Sam Daly's and Jean Smart is in it hey
uh and uh every time I guess waking
comes up I always just think like Adam
Sandler liked that movie he wanted to
make that movie but Skyler was like no
this is my movie like we want to make it
but he went to the the production
company that Adam was with I mean I
guess it's Sony and something else
um but happy Madison a thing oh yeah it
does a happy Madison ding ding ding ding
ding to see this is where I don't come
from and Adam Sandler household or where
I'm like oh right yeah yeah yeah uh yeah
it's all good anywho dang Sandler
watches the movie and cries yeah just
once that could have been me
yeah yeah yep that's the thing that's
happened crazy story but we still got to
do ADR at Sony Studios because I think
Adam was still like nice well he's
obviously nice but I think they still
were able to go through a different
maybe an indie production company maybe
through Adam I don't know but I got to
go into a Sony studio thing to do ADR
and that like that bro they're huge
they're so big John it was so cool I bet
I felt super cool then I was like wow I
would wow you are accepted I hated ADR
it's the worst ADR does seem quite
difficult yeah and uh it seems like they
didn't have to use too much of it here
there were times where I could hear the
digits
in the background yeah but but matching
lips and then matching the the tonality
of the scene like yeah I do not I've
done a little bit of ADR and it is a it
is it's a beast boy you're like I know
it's me and it's my mouth moving I
cannot this is I don't I can't redo it I
can't can't do it I'm trying and it's
never perfect and it bugs the s-h-i-t
out of me I'm like I convinced one
director not to use a Dr one movie with
the scene that was outside and he's like
you're right we're just gonna do the
regular we'll just Juice It Up and I was
like thank you so dude you direct you
slightly directed I slightly did it
because I was like listen to the
difference it's not that big of a deal
this one is so much better the fact that
you get a little environment in the
background doesn't bother me that much
versus me doing ADR I was like I'm
trying to give you the juice here man I
can't do it the juice Kim couldn't do it
John it's okay because it's okay you
tried I tried just like the water boy he
tried he tried all you can do is try all
you can do is try and every time we cut
back to your house Play Devil Went Down
this is an odd show I was like you've
got other music in this way like I I am
obviously it amused me I found it
Charming but I was also like did you run
out of music button until you're like we
should just make this yeah just use the
[__] out of this queue that we bought
what would your song be if we went to
your house ooh yeah John give it to us
or you could give like two options yeah
it's like what would you choose versus
what would it for like truly be yeah I
guess uh uh for whatever reason we are
family comes to mind if I if I imagine
what it might actually be
uh uh if it was me and I was just
wanting my own home establishing music
um
let's see
um dang that's hard right really hard I
wouldn't know how to because there's
every song at your disposal and you're
like I don't want to go with something
like heavy and badass because like
that's not what being at home is like
you know I'm like what's like a pleasant
but upbeat song
yeah
I don't know
see the thing is when people ask you to
like name songs then you don't know of
any songs you can that me they're like
what are the I can hear the elements of
what the song would be then I'll get in
my car to go home and I'll be like oh
it's these 10 songs yeah exactly you
know it'll just be five four by by
gorillas what's your what's your what's
your home music
oh I don't know is there's a song that's
like Witchy Woman right how does it go
Joan
woman ah you're guessing yeah I was
trying to do like is there like a black
velvet song I love the color black
except my house is very vibrant John I
don't know this game is this question
this song and we could Corner the K-pop
boom baby he's got it that's that's the
tag right there that's the Zinger yep
but uh I like the Louisiana Vibes the
Bayou Vibes that was also one of those
things where it's like okay we got this
like just because they chose to set it
here we have all these random sort of
Bayou flavored gags and things and all
the like alligators they're eating like
they really went to town on making
living in Louisiana it seemed like a a
real back woodsy experience yeah and uh
it's funny because also too talking to
to friends of mine who like live in
areas of the South uh I also wonder how
like if somebody from there was to hear
like you know a Cajun accent or you know
that that uh you know that Lou that that
that drone that like very sugary kind of
drop oh that's good John ah dude I do
appreciate Joel
I don't think I could do it you got
you're halfway there though I'm trying
to I could maybe do Southern but it
doesn't sound like your drawl that
you're doing so I can't I can't do it
it's okay study up come back yeah but I
always wonder what people who are like
from around there think when they hear
these accents and if anybody's like
really like I bet Kathy Bates probably
like did her homework yeah because she
had like a real again like a real great
grip on that point she also won an Oscar
sure right yeah and I love that she's
like game for yeah for like yeah she's
you know she's I mean before we had
character actress Margo Martindale we
Kathy Bates all right we still got Kathy
baseball we're lucky to live on a Kathy
Bates timeline
hallelujah oh getting my hands on some
nice glacial water that's right
someone's like what is in that glacier
water other than the the innate chill
yeah which alone I mean I love that that
came back I thought that was a fun like
McGuffin thing and two like the whole
like yeah the the the notebook they they
threw down on the Schindler's List slash
later on Sin City effective like we're
doing the black and white with the color
yep um but I like the way they used it
even just as a visual joke and you got
the afros and everything using that tool
of visualization you know as something
that the whole team can get into in some
ways like he empowers Bobby that way
then he starts telling other players to
use that and then finally Bobby comes
around is like you should use this
visualization technique as well it
seemed like something that is it was
nicely tied around for this movie story
but also felt like a vague kind of thing
that you might be able to apply to an
actual sport yeah yeah right or
speaking event yeah imagine them all in
their underwear that never works but
like in this movie it would it would it
would yeah and uh and water always works
water always good for you the Lord's uh
the Lords yes wine I thought right he's
um he turned water to wine though John I
feel like he was just he's knocking him
back and you know that's how he can
I guess he'll Heal the World heal in the
world yeah well guys we are healed by
your presence joining us for this
reaction and yeah leave us your thoughts
on the movie any other movies you would
like to see us check out certainly any
other Adam Sandler joints you might want
to see us react to If we haven't seen
him yet uh leave that like on the video
subscribe to the channel and hey last
but not least let's do a little picture
Daniel the Gallagher Daniel now look I
know we usually talk about your
pharmaceutical background wow and
whatnot but if there's drugs
that's where I was going and I set you
up and you just you just sailed that
ball through that through the field goal
yes yeah you saved it we did it yeah I
did it John started a sports metaphor
got lost in the basketball and you
brought it back to football yeah and I
appreciate that and hey I mean I I'm
sure being from Scotland you appreciate
American football uh as much as we do
but I'm also sure that aside from all
your drug dealings yeah uh you probably
know to appreciate Nature's Most
Bountiful medicine right because you
need that to knock down the drugs water
I mean you've got to put those you don't
want to put dry drug they need to be you
know
um hydrated before they go in or after
they go in you wanna
that way they're just like moving
through the bloodstream faster that's
what we want with drugs right that's how
we do the drugs I'm taking your advice
yeah I am yeah glacial water I am the
water soul for this yeah definitely and
you and Daniel are going to guide me
into a a life of junkitude yeah so hey
man keep drinking that water with your
drugs yeah and stay pledged to the
patreon it's important if you if you run
out of you know money for if you have to
choose between drugs and the patreon we
hope you choose the patreon oh oh oh
right I meant of patreon I meant the
patreon buddy I meant either way yeah
he's drinking water totally water I
meant to actually say water
[Music]